mais en attendant la réouverture des
discothèques en france les soirées
clandestines continue à paris
l'illustration la nuit dernière avec une
fête géante aux invalides qui s'est
soldée avec un affrontement avec les
forces de l'ordre
un rassemblement festifs improvisés sur
les réseaux sociaux
au final des centaines de jeunes se sont
réunis pour une soirée intitulée projet
x en référence au film américain dans
lequel une fête dégénère
peu après le couvre-feu de 23 heures la
police est venue disperser la foule
les forces de l'ordre ont fait usage de
gaz lacrymogènes contre des individus à
lançant des projectiles
la tension est finalement retombé aux
alentours de minuit